la pauvreté est un problème mondial
comment le résoudre à la chine ce pays
de plus de 1,4 milliard d'habitants fait
de gros efforts pour lutter contre la
pauvreté
la journaliste anna nedeljko entreprend
un voyage à travers la province du
fujian dans le sud-est de la chine
elle y parcourt ces hautes montagnes sa
mère
on s'emmêle dans les cordes et goûtent
aux difficultés du quotidien des
fermiers
je n'aurais jamais cru que les ignames
puisse ressembler ce afin de tenter de
lever le voile sur le secret du miracle
économique chinois
je n'ai jamais été dans une maison comme
ça il faut faire très attention pour ne
pas tondre east
et comprendre comment sortir un peuple
de la pauvreté
le projet elle au china apporte quelques
réponses
la province de fujian se trouve dans le
sud est de la chine
presque tout son territoire est couvert
de chaînes de montagnes mais cette
province possède également le littoral
le plus escarpés de chine
la mère héros dans la terre se rapproche
des montagnes la proportion de surfaces
agricoles par habitant est l'une des
plus faibles de chine
la pauvreté a donc toujours été le lot
de ses habitants mais les temps changent
à dean le programme d'éradication de la
pauvreté en chine
un slogan publicitaire les oiseaux
faible devrait décoller en premier qui
est alité volet chinois cela signifie
quoi paris si tu veux sortir de la
pauvreté
il faut faire le premier pas et
travailler aussi dur que possible
ensuite tu as tu peux voler vers les
sommets du succès des titres nationaux
ou spear dans cet épisode je vais vous
raconter comment les hobbies populaire
et l'artisanat aide à lutter contre la
pauvreté en chine faisant un voeu je
vais attraper un précieux faisant
argenté je pense que je lai apprendre
pourquoi des herbes médicinales sont mis
dans ses baskets tendance
je me sens pas l'odeur houston et
découvrir pourquoi les filles du groupe
ethnique chez son psy doué pour les
combats avec des bâtons en bambou
[Musique]
je suis dans le comté de hyundai près du
village de daichi sur la montagne dont
diane qui est à plus de 1500 mètres
d'altitude
j'ai escaladé cette montagne pour une
bonne raison j'ai l'intention de
chaussée un animal extrêmement rare le
faisan argenté ces oiseaux sont au bord
de la disparition
donc je ne ferai que les prendre en
photo ah oui il ne faut pas relâcher au
photo n'est pas facile vous devez passer
des heures dans une tente étroite dans
les montagnes froid donc il faut bien
s'habiller des lignes dans le village de
dax qui est un endroit idéal pour les
chasseurs de photos car il ya une
station d'observation des oiseaux rares
confortable le faisant à genté est un
oiseau important dans la culture
chinoise en raison de sa beauté
fantastique et l'un était surnommé le
magicien de la forêt au moyen âge ce
faisant a été représentée sur la tenue
officielle des fonctionnaires du
gouvernement chinois mais le magicien de
la forêt est en fait en oiseaux rares et
timides vous est incroyablement chanceux
si vous en rencontrez un dans la nature
les photographes de toute la chine
viennent ici pour le faisan à genté
monsieur chen a construit une station
d'observation des oiseaux ici près d'une
cascade perché dans les montagnes kg est
devenu il ne fait pas de bruit s'il vous
plaît
mettez vos affaires là la pluie est
arrivée à un très mauvais moment
on dit que tous les oiseaux se cachent
dans les buissons quand le temps est
comme ça est ce le cas maintenant et je
parcouru tout ce chemin pour rien
venez vite les faisans sont là
heureusement pour nous malgré la pluie
la cible de notre chasse aux photos est
là et il n'est pas seul
les voilà et si proche il y en a trois
une famille entière dans le temps
monsieur chen était informaticien mais
il a également été photographe amateur
pendant des années il a finalement
décidé de faire de sa passion un métier
maintenant il possède ces stations et
donne des cours de photo
le but de mon atelier de former autant
de vrai photographe animalier que
possible en chine les professionnels de
haut niveau et les amateurs
inexpérimentés comme moi viennent dans
cette station ici en forme et fourni un
équipement spécial à tout le monde alors
je pars en chasse le faisan est un
oiseau assez craintifs
car donc nous avons besoin de temps pour
nous en approcher ensuite nous
essaierons de le photographier comme il
pleut aujourd'hui nous allons filmer au
ralenti je peux essayer
allez-y n'ayez pas peur et je les perds
du poids dessus
photographiée en faisant argenté en vol
et exigent une grande habilité
il faut patienter observé ils se
déplacent le long de la cascade très
lentement
il faut attendre qu'il décolle de l'état
ce n'est pas aussi simple qu'on pourrait
le penser en regardant quelqu'un d'autre
le faire en réalité un photographe doit
être incroyablement patient et très en
forme s'il peut photographier des
oiseaux c'est énorme objective à longues
focales sont assez lourds et vous n'avez
qu'une fraction de seconde pour faire
une bonne photo
la prochaine fois appuyé fort
j'envoie un parfait a maintenant appuyé
j'ai l'impression qu'il se lève la voix
la wii malades les yeux je crois
maintenant je sais à quel point la
chasse aux photos peut être excitant
et c'est moi qui a fait cette photo
didon c'est génial
vous trouvez ça vient vraiment très bon
avec de l'entraînement ce sera encore
mieux très bien je vais en acheter un
comme ça j'ai tellement froid astiz
hollande et choco veut sauver la bourse
vers une seule photo les amateurs
d'oiseaux sont prêts à escalader les
montagnes et à rester assis pendant des
heures je sors je ne sais toujours pas
exactement comment sommet aujourd'hui
j'ai réussi à attraper un magicien de la
forêt dans mon objectif d'appareil photo
quand les gros merci monsieur chen
merci merci la station de monsieur chen
est d'une grande aide pour le petit
village de daiichi située au pied de ces
hautes montagnes tout d'abord monsieur
chen fournit des emplois à la population
locale ensuite tous ceux qui viennent
voir les oiseaux doivent payer un droit
d'entrée achetés un permis de chasse
photo et payer les transports qui les
amène dans les montagnes une partie de
cet argent sert à améliorer le village
qui sort progressivement de la pauvreté
ainsi le passe temps d un aident les
autres à mieux vivre
jeu lors du 19e congrès national du
parti communiste chinois le camarade chi
jean ping a qualifié la protection de la
nature de grande stratégie de la chine
pour le millénaire je pense que c'est un
point clé pourquoi car c'est notre
ressource
nous avons une eau de bonne qualité de
belles montagnes mais surtout un bon
environnement comment savons nous que
c'est lucas ce sont les animaux sauvages
qui le prouvent
ils sont parfaitement protégés ici je
dis au revoir à ses montagnes
pittoresque et me dirige vers le
littoral de fujian où vit le groupe
ethnique jeu mon objectif est de
maîtriser l'ancien art martial du combat
au bâton en bambou glee mur d'argile
manque d'électricité et de service
public apprécie ce manteau imperméable
et fabriqué en paille
non mais ce n'est pas une maison
paysanne ordinaire c'est une véritable
machine à remonter le temps
dès que vous franchissez le seuil vous
êtes propulsé du passé au présent et
après tout cette ut ne se trouve pas
dans un village isolé admet au coeur du
village de doune chan confortable et
moderne cette ancienne maison de
fermiers illustre la différence entre le
passé et le présent
la maison a été déplacé vers la côte
depuis un village de montagne isolés qui
a abrité autrefois toute la population
de dông chan ces personnes appartiennent
au groupe ethnique des cheveux qui
vivaient dans une pauvreté épouvantables
dans les montagnes les travaux dont le
district urbain de nice des ont commencé
en 1987
la situation ici était alors déplorable
dans cette région montagneuse
il n'y avait ni routes ni eau ni
électricité rocher pas d'école pas de
matériel médical j'ai pas de chaînes de
télévision et pas de magasin ce quartier
était si pauvre qu'il a été décidé de
déplacer ses résidents vers des endroits
avec de meilleures conditions
au cours des trente dernières années
plus de 23000 personnes ont reçu un
nouveau logement dans le cadre du
programme de réinstallation
le gouvernement a construit deux beaux
villages comme celui-ci avec toutes les
commodités de chaque famille a une
maison de trois étages avec terrasse
mais le principal c'est que les gens qui
vivent sur cette côte prosper ont des
emplois
certains cultivent et récoltent des
algues tandis que d'autres s'occupent de
leur traitement
nous vivions dans une très vieille
maison délabrée avec un toit qui fuyait
quand il pleuvait il y avait de l'eau
dans la maison ici dans ce nouveau lieu
les maisons sont bien meilleures en bon
état c'est plus pratique pour aller à
l'école
la vie est bien meilleur on mari gagne
environ 10 mille yuans par mois
et moi je fais entre 4000 et 5000
c'est un très bon revenu pour notre
famille oh la la plupart des habitants
de donc chant appartiennent au groupe
ethnique jeu ils ont leur propre langue
leur culture et leur ancienne tradition
alors je me lance dans une expédition
ethnographique passionnante
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre bus cars nié les faits ne pousse
pas sur un arbre sans racine
selon un ancien dicton chinois autrement
dit un peuple qui oublie ses coutures
disparaîtra mais les cheveux ne risque
rien parce qu'il préserve précieusement
leurs traditions et surtout leur chance
[Musique]
cela peut sembler étrange mais pour les
garçons et les filles je chantais est un
moyen de trouver un compagnon du début à
la fin ces chansons ne sont qu'une pure
improvisation vous pouvez chanter tout
ce qui vous passe par la tête
alors on sait jamais peut-être que je
trouverai un fiancé ici ça s'appelle la
chanson do you c'est une chanson
populaire qui raconte l'histoire d'un
garçon et d'une fille qui tombe amoureux
c'est ça parle d'amour je dois apprendre
au moins un couple est elle réussie s'il
vous plaît apprenez mois au moins un
premier verre de cette chanson oh pas
facile
[Musique]
ia nostang jaya et bien j'ai appris pas
parfaitement bien sûr mais j'ai presque
après le premier couplet maintenant nous
allons la chanter avec ce magnifique
ensemble folklorique alosi et après je
ne sais pas on m'a dit qu'en plus
dévaluer l'apparence de l'autre les
garçons et les filles vérifie c'est leur
future campagne on peut interpréter une
chanson
bref si vous voulez vous marier approté
à chanter et à vous habiller en fait ce
que j'ai sur la tête c'est une coiffe de
fiancé mais je ne vois pas encore de
beaux partis à l'horizon les chiens sont
un très petit peuple le comparer à la
population du pays dont préserver notre
culture est une tâche que nous nous
fixons dès le plus jeune âge c'est
essentiel pour que notre culture ne
disparaissent pas et ne sombre pas dans
la nuit non seulement les cheveux ça
vient chanter mais ils savent aussi se
défendre et les filles ne sont pas moins
doués pour ça que les garçons le combat
au bâton en bambou est un ancien art
martial pratiqué par le peuple le cheveu
il y avait autrefois beaucoup de bandits
dans les montagnes et les fermiers
devait apprendre à se défendre et à
défendre leurs familles je vais essayer
je peux
ce n'est pas si difficile cependant il
faut trois à cinq ans pour maîtriser
pleinement l'art du combat au bâton en
bambou il est con ce n'est pas si simple
je suis un peu fatigué pourquoi vous
faites ça les filles il y avait beaucoup
de bandits dans notre région auparavant
nous continuons donc à apprendre le
bouchon combat de bâton pour nous
défendre
c'est aussi un bon moyen de rester en
forme
enfin sociedad
c'est par les jeunes c'est angie ou du
vide c'est incroyable de voir que la
jeune génération préserve aussi
passionnément ces traditions en ce qui
me concerne le combat au bâton n'est pas
très pratiquante allons donc je vais
devoir choisir d'autres choses sur la
prochaine fois
[Musique]
vous retrouvez une paire de chaussures
plus confortable je vais à jinjiang un
grand centre industriel
mon objectif est de voir de mes propres
yeux à quoi ressemble le miracle
économique chinois dans les grandes
villes
[Musique]
j'ai du temps pour faire un peu de
shopping
donc je cherche quelque chose
d'intéressant
regardez cela je crois que c'est un
phénix peut-être un dragon mais ça a
l'air vraiment cool surtout dire ok avec
maintenant les chaussures
[Musique]
si la chine l usine du monde
jin jing l usine de la chine a elle même
les vêtements et les chaussures de
nombreuses marques internationales
renommées sont fabriqués ici
cette ville de deux millions d'habitants
n'est pas appelée la capitale de la
chaussure pour rien ces dernières années
la chine a essayé de développer ses
propres marques de mode plutôt que des
marques uniquement étrangères
bonjour bonjour c'est confortable ça
vous plaît darwin ou et elle me plaisent
beaucoup
confortable est tout simplement superbe
elles contiennent des herbes chinoise
anti-odeurs donc ça sont toujours frais
nous les produisons ici j'ai vraiment de
la chance mais ce jeanne n'est pas un
simple vendeur
il possède également une usine de
chaussures je me demande quel genre
d'herbes chinoises
ils mettent dans leurs chaussures en moi
je peux voir comment ils sont fabriqués
bien sûr pas de problème ça changer de
chaussures et je vous emmène à notre
usine d'accord parfait très bien
lusine de monsieur jack est une énorme
installation en pleine activité
des dizaines d'hommes travaillent sur
une chaîne de production qui ne s'arrête
pas une minute
j'ai hâte de découvrir le secret quels
sont les herbes chinoises qu'il met dans
les baskets
les attila vous souvenez de ces
chaussures que vous avez essayé
vous vous souvenez à quel point c'était
confortable cette semelle intérieure est
fabriqué à l'aide de la technologie
noire basée sur des recettes secrètes de
la médecine chinoise
regardez alors si on découpe on trouve
des herbes à l'intérieur non non non
nous faisons une sorte de bouillon
d'herbe le filtre on l'a en fusion dans
les semelles puis c'est chaud sentais un
peu
nous avons même déposé une demande de
brevet
comme monsieur john m'a expliqué ce
mélange est composée de huit herbes et
de plantes médicinales entre autres est
liée à la racine de ce type à de la peau
de du riob 2 les corses de glee et même
des pétales d'orchidées
[Musique]
toutes les chaussures sont conçus ici
dans un véritable studio de design
messieurs jane n'embauchent que des
jeunes designers qui créent des articles
à la mode pour les gens de leur âge
aujourd'hui mais ce jam est designer et
fondateur d'une marque de mode mais il a
commencé sa carrière en tant que simple
ouvrier en 2004 j'ai fondé ma propre
entreprise
car une petite usine de chaussures
familiale jamais ma première entreprise
a échoué au fond parce que je n'avais
pas assez d'expérience il australien et
cela m'a coûté plusieurs millions de
johann bodin cette expérience elle est
très très stressante
en 2008 j'ai quitté jinzhang pour
voyager à travers le pays qui tient et
même à l'étranger
de nos jours l usine de trang fabrique
des centaines de modèles de chaussures
si vous regardez de plus près le logo de
l'entreprise vous verrez un caractère
chinois qui signifie bonté aujourd'hui
les jeunes veulent être branché à ce
centre audio après mais les oublis de
plus en plus le respect et la
gentillesse nous voulons préserver ces
valeurs à travers nos produits afin de
préserver la culture et cet esprit trois
groupes ainsi un plus grand nombre de
chinois han et les ting t3f 5 mois
monsieur jack est né dans une famille
très pauvre qui n'avait jamais assez de
nourriture
il est né dans la ville ancienne de
genting située à 350 km de jinjiang et
laissait d'embaucher des gens de cette
région pour les aider à sortir de la
pauvreté
il ya beaucoup de monde ici combien vous
avez d'employés notre entreprise compte
plus de 300 employés
la plupart sont de changxing comme moi
monsieur chaîne vient de là aussi il
travaillait avec sa femme depuis cinq ou
six ans nous vivons dans un village je
suis reconnaissant à ma soeur jeanne de
nous avoir donné l'opportunité de
travailler ici notre vie s'est vraiment
améliorée
l'usiné de chaussures de monsieur john
est l'une des centaines d'entreprises de
fujian impliqués dans le programme de
soutien du gouvernement
en chine il est commun de voir les
grands centres industriels aider les
provinces pauvres de dix mille personnes
de changqing vivent maintenant à jing
zhang plus de 200 nouvelles entreprises
sont enregistrées ici
parmi elles il ya de grandes sociétés
mais également d'autres gérés par des
entreprises de jinjiang elle en
coopération avec celle ci jinzhang est
désormais un véritable centre d'affaires
ça seulement un endroit où on gagne un
peu d'argent de poche
c'est très important pour les deux
parties afin de continuer à se
développer et à travailler ensemble
j'ai déjà tellement entendu parler de
chant thing que je dois absolument y
aller
cette ville à la réputation de centre de
l'un des plus anciens artisanat de la
chine la sculpture sur bois
mon objectif est de percer tous les
secrets de cet art ancien
[Musique]
gucci jean thing est l'une des plus
anciennes villes de chine
figurez vous que ces murs et tours ont
mille trois cents ans les anciennes
coutumes et l'artisanat chinois sont
soigneusement préservés ainsi
on va regarder ses sculptures entrons
bonjour bonjour
regardez comme c'est beau je me suis
toujours demandé combien de temps cela
pourrait prendre pour faire une nouvelle
sculpture comme celle ci à la main je
suppose que c'est au moins un an
mais peut-être que je me trompe pas la
boutique de monsieur jane est située
dans une rue commerçante appelé tient
tout dié elle a dix siècles
d'après la légende ce lieu a toujours
été occupé par un magasin de sculpture
sur bois
[Applaudissements]
o o
que c'est beau qu'est ce que c'est c'est
le dieu du bonheur ça serait pas par
hasard c'est lui à qui il faut frotter
le ventre et faire le veut oui cette
statue réalise vos voeux j'ai eu de la
chance de venir alors je vais faire un
voeu
[Musique]
la sculpture sur bois est l'un des arts
appliqués les plus populaires en chine
il y à des siècles la société chinoise
primitive avait déjà ces sculpteurs
habile l'art a atteint l'apogée de sa
popularité au 14e siècle sous la
dynastie ming
ouais ok ce que c'est
un bougeoir décoratifs en bambou naturel
très tôt d'une incroyable ce bonbon
aurait pu être transformé en papier mais
le voici sous cette forme sur cette
étagère
[Musique]
au moyen âge tous chinois plus ou moins
et sans parler des rois décorer sa
maison avec des sculptures en bois
il ya énormément de ce que tu renvoies
ici qu'est ce que cette eau qui s est
beau dit norma je me pose la question
vous et c'est vous qui faites tout ça a
la même façon à moi mes employés a donc
c'est une usine à je n'ai jamais vu une
production pareil on peut aller regarder
bien sûr l'atelier n'est pas loin je
vais vous accompagnez génial ça sera
super intéressant l'atelier où messieurs
djalma à mener est situé en périphérie
de la ville il est assez spacieux les
quelques artisans que nous voyons ici
sont absorbés par le travail hors tac au
travail 1 comment ça se fait bonjour
bonjour je m'appelle ana qu'est ce que
vous faites c'est une statue de bouddha
sacha c'est magnifique ça vous pratiquer
ce métier depuis longtemps depuis 23 ans
mon grand père était aussi sculpteur sur
bois
il a transmis son savoir faire à mon
père et mon père à moi même j'aimais
travailler le bois quand j'étais enfant
il j'aime toujours ça à nos sculptures
sont entièrement fait à la main bien que
ce soit de moins en moins courant de nos
jours
on peut comparer la sculpture sur bois
un rituel magique
je suis incapable de comprendre comment
ces baisses culture peuvent être créés à
l'aide d'un simple c'est aux abois je
t'envoie c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
difficile quand on fabrique un objet
pareil celle ci représente un être
humain est la partie la plus difficile
et c'est toujours le regard est
l'expression du visage
c'est un travail soigné en faire
ressortir d'un morceau de bois comme
celui les yeux
au final on a une très belle pièce
magistralement exécuté je dois admettre
que ce qui m'étonne le plus c'est la
précision avec laquelle les artisans
travaillent
pensez-y un faux mouvement et tout le
travail est fichu et cela coûterait de
l'argent
presque toutes les sculptures sont
faites en acajou leaf le tremble le
bambou la racine de boulot de montagne
le liège et même le bois de santal sont
également souvent utilisé réaliser une
statue comme celle ci prend environ six
jours ces six jours seulement je pensais
au moins six mois pour créer une beauté
pareil l'ancien métiers de la sculpture
sur bois est important pour la lutte
contre la pauvreté
c'est un bon gain pas pour ceux qui
fabrique et vend ses merveilleux objet
nos clients sont principalement des
touristes maintenant mais les habitants
s'enrichissent et commencent à acheter
des choses de ce genre
nous avons ouvert deux nouveaux magasins
récemment je ne suis plus si inquiet
pour les ventes maintenant car elles
correspondent à peu près notre volume de
production nous augmentons maintenant la
production
cela signifie que les salaires des
ouvriers augmente et que personne ne
souffre de la pauvreté
le gouvernement chinois a fixé un
objectif très ambitieux éradiquer la
pauvreté dans un proche avenir
et chaque et construire une société de
moyenne aisance pour tous d'après ce que
j'ai vu lors de mon voyage dans la
province de fujian
ils sont en bonne voie pour accomplir
cette mission
[Musique]
la chine poursuit son objectif lentement
mais sûrement en suivant l'ancien dicton
un voyage de milieux commence par le
premier pas et en russie et nous dit
celui qui marche arrivera toujours au
bout de la route
[Musique]